The radical left leaning anti theist
environmentalists tend to make the case
that the predations of the Western
capitalist system are a consequence of
the injunction that was delivered in
Genesis by God to man to go out and
dominate the earth.
David Suzuki has talked a lot about this
by the way.
They believe that that statement has
given rise to our inappropriate
assumption that we have the right to
exert control over the world and that
that's what's turned us into these
terrible predatory monsters sometimes
described as counselors on the face of
the earth or viruses that have inhabited
the entire ecosystem who are doing
nothing but one wandering everywhere and
wreaking havoc as rapidly as we possibly
can,
which is another perspective on the
essential element of humankind that I
find absolutely deplorable.
I mean,
if you look at the historical record,
for example,
even casually,
you'll find out that as early as,
as late as the late 18 hundreds,
18,
95,
thereabouts,
Thomas Huxley,
who was Elvis Huxley's grandfather and a
great defender of Darwin,
prepared a report for the British
government on ocean sustainability and
his conclusion was fish away.
Guys.
Man,
there are so many fish out there.
The oceans are so inexhaustible that no
matter how hard humanity tried for,
for any number of years,
the probability that we could do more
than put a dent in what was out there
was zero.
Now Huxley turned out to be wrong.
He didn't realize that our population
was going to spike so dramatically,
partly because we got a little bit rich
and our children's stopped dying at the
rate of 60 percent before they were one
years old and you know,
we actually managed to populate the
earth with a few people,
but it wasn't really until 1960 or so
that we woke up to the fact that there
were so many of us that we actually had
to start paying attention to what we
were doing to the planet.
And that's like what 50 years ago?
Well,
we've just started to develop the
technology,
have the wherewithal to understand that
the whole world might be well considered
a garden and we need to live inside the
proper balance between culture and order
or culture and,
and,
and chaos.
Before that we were spending all of our
time just trying not to die and usually
very unsuccessfully,
so I don't agree with that
interpretation of the opening section of
Genesis.
I don't believe that it's given human
being has the right to act as super
predators on the planet.
I think that instead the proper
environment for human beings is
presented quite properly as a garden and
that the role of people and that's
explicitly stated in,
in the second story of Adam and Eve was
to tend the garden and that means to
make the proper decisions and to make
sure that everything thrives and
flourishes and and so that it's good for
the things that are living there that
aren't just people,
but also good for the people too.
So fine.
I think we can.
We could least note that that's a
slightly different take on the story
than the that ultimately cynical
interpretation that's so commonly put
forward today.